foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Peters Morgan I'm censored tonight
Boris Johnson deliberately lied to the
House of Commons then mounted a campaign
of abuse against the MPS who exposed it
as a staggering shameful report lesbear
the extent of his deception deceit will
debate whether this is finally my view
hopefully the end of the Boris show
of champion cyclist Hannah arenzman
abandons her Olympic dream and quits the
sport after losing to a biological man
who joins me live with the Olympic
swimmer and women's rights campaigner
Sharon Davis and Western Legend Andrews
says he can't write another musical
because he's afraid of being canceled it
canceled culture killing culture
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored well
good evening for London welcome to peers
of organ on censor the sun is shining
the bars of paint many people are
gearing up for the summer holidays that
is an oasis of normality you might say
and very easy to forget that just three
years ago the world would become a very
different very lonely quite deadly place
as kovid ripped through this country
Boris Johnson ordered us to do this
you must stay at home
What followed in the subsequent months
were countless stories of unimaginable
grief and sacrifice remember this little
boy Ismail age 13 buried Alone by men in
hazmat suits because his mother and
siblings were ordered to self-isolate
the late Queen sat masked and alone as
she mourned her husband as 73 years
Boris Johnson's government plastered
posters of dying covert victims across
the country with the words look in the
eyes and tell her you never bend the
rules
but Boris Johnson bent the rules and
most of his staff bent the rules and
regardless of what you now think of
those rules with the benefit of
hindsight Boris Johnson was a man who
made those rules and ordered the rest of
the country to follow them today's
report by the Privileges committee the
result of a year-long investigation into
whether he lied to Parliament about
breaking his own rules is excoriating
there's a lot in it and the conclusions
are damning I'll come to those but for
me the whole thing is summed up by this
jaw-dropping firsthand testimony
submitted as evidence by a downstreet
official I'm going to read it in full so
that you can understand exactly what
this report says
this person who worked at number 10 said
during the pandemic number 10 despite
setting the rules to the country was
slow to enforce any rules in the
building the Press office Wine Time
Fridays continued throughout social
distancing was not enforced mask wearing
was not enforced I once inquired two
redacted name in March 2020 whether we
should be wearing masks and was told the
science advice was there was no point
and it had very little effect on the
spread of covid this is all part of a
wider culture I'm not adhering to any
rules
number 10 was like an island oasis of
normality
operational notes were sent out from a
security team to be mindful of the
cameras outside the door not to go out
in groups into socially distance it was
all a pantomime
one of those booze soap parties took
place on the night before the late Queen
sat alone to mourn her husband with the
rest of the country banned from
socializing staff inside the building
where he lived and worked continued to
party while the rest of the country and
much of the world gave up everything to
keep each other safe and when the truth
came out which it always does in the end
Boris Johnson did what Boris Johnson
does best he lied
I have been repeatedly assured since
these allegations emerged that there was
no party and that and that no kobit
rules were broken and that is what I
have been repeatedly assured
just a massive lie the investigation
under whether he lied was carried out by
seven MPS four of them conservatives who
were all brexiteers they say he's guilty
of deliberately lying to Parliament and
their committee multiple times they say
he leaked details of the confidential
report when it was sent to him last week
the amount of a campaign of abuse and
attempted intimidation against his
colleagues and if he hadn't already
resigned in disgrace he'd be facing an
unprecedented 90-day suspension
now your face is being banned from the
Parliamentary estate altogether remember
this isn't some Rogue back bench
this was the Prime Minister
and his response today as ever is to con
is to cry conspiracy and blame everybody
else this is rubbish he Roars a lie a
deranged conclusion a kangaroo court
patently absurd Boris Johnson has now
become Donald Trump with the thesaurus
the fact is that Boris is a Serial liar
who's been saved from pre to previous
jobs for lying he's now lying about the
people who've exposed his lies and
calling them Liars
this report is 108 pages long thirty
thousand words of Shame and it is a
shameful read it's shameful for Boris
Johnson and is shameful for this country
most former Prime Ministers go into the
annals of History
Boris frankly can get in the bin well
joining me now has talked to these
political letters of Kate McCann and the
former special advisor to Boris Johnson
Alex Crowley who received an Obe in the
former prime minister's resignation
honors list and I'm also joined remotely
by restoring and author of Johnson at
number 10 which is in his own way an
excoriating account of Boris Johnson Sir
Anthony Selden so welcome to all three
of you okay
um Boris appears to have gone full nuke
Trump he's attacking the institution
he's saying it's all a Witch Hunt it's
all lies this is real Champion stuff
isn't it
yeah I think it is and actually I don't
think that's the only element that is
causing concern in his statement today
he mentions Rishi sunak by name and his
supporters are doing the same thing now
there's a reason for that that they are
seeking to envelop where she seem like
the current prime minister and others
who were in office at the time in
everything that goes along with this
report to suggest that anything that
Boris Johnson knew wish you soon act new
too that's going to make his life
incredibly difficult the prime ministers
but it also is the report indicates it
has an effect on democracy and it is
already having an impact within
Parliament within the conservative party
there are those MPS now who were talking
about suggestions that the committee
members those Tories on the committee
May well be parachuted into safe seats
Nadine dorries has said as much that she
will be keeping a close eye on what
happens next well you interviewed her
today let's just take a quick look at
the clip from that
it is actually the case that this report
smells as though something is quite
wrong 90 days suspension 90 days it is
far more than even Boris Johnson's worst
critics thought would happen even his
worst critics were saying maybe he'll
get 20. we're hoping he'd get 20. even
they are utterly amazed but he got 90
days there is something very untoward
about what has happened in this report
here's the thing though he didn't get 90
days originally they they made it worse
because of his attack on Parliament on
the institution on all his MP colleagues
right I mean that's why he got 90 days
yeah there's a huge extra section of
this final report which details exactly
why they have chosen to do that it talks
in this report about the attack on the
committee carrying it out its remit from
the democratically elected house amounts
to an attack on our Democratic
institutions they are taking this in
itself very seriously they're saying
that actually that is a serious further
contempt which is why they added to that
original penalty which we believe was
around 40 days and then was right so
they're more than doubled it because of
his ridiculous Antics since he's read
the report he's read the report he's
seen how bad it is and he's gone full
Trump which is to attack the institution
which has created this supposed attack
on him well in fact it's a very well
researched and detailed report by a
committee that is dominated by his own
conservatives yeah and I I think anybody
who reads this report you know look you
can go back and forth the clip that you
showed of him in the House of Commons
there where he is accused of misleading
the house he actually said no covered
rules were broken in this report he he
does concede actually what he meant to
say was guidance he also says he was
told repeatedly and he concedes in the
report that he wasn't there are a number
of different things like that scattered
throughout these Pages whereby he said
that the Gathering in the garden was
because the cabinet secretary had
resigned but the cabinet secretary
actually resigned a month later when you
add all of those things up clearly those
writing this report have done so knowing
that it will be absolutely heavily
criticized by Boris Johnson's supporters
but I think when you read it you you
conclude ultimately as they do that he
did mislead the house and not just that
but he was deliberately disingenuous and
doing yeah he's a liar Alex Crowley you
got an honor in the resignation I don't
think anyone should have got any of
these offers right I don't think if
you're a prime it's just a separate
issue but I I just think if you are if
you leave as prime minister in shame and
disgrace why are you getting to have an
honors list I mean what do you think of
that argument above something else well
look I mean it's it's it's it's a very
odd Quirk of our constitutional system
that a prime minister who leaves office
either with a great reputation or a
terrible reputation gets to nominate
people for honors and of course their
successor has to sign it off a successor
of course doesn't have to sign it off
there's nothing there's nothing nothing
in law that says there's success do you
feel comfortable get you've got an OB
right yeah and this was for what well
the official title is for political and
public service these are the sorts of
things that I didn't know I'd got it
until about two or three days what do
you think you did to deserve out of
Interest well um uh personally I don't
think I did I did a great deal to
deserve it because it's a massive honor
and and I you know I don't think of
myself as that important however what I
will say is that there are lots of
people who work in politics for for
labor for the tourists for all sorts of
other political parties and it is a
public service now you can criticize
people that work in politics and say
Well they're all useless they're all
undertake except Etc but you have to
have people working for those parties
for those institutions in order for us
okay but you've been you've been given
this Honor by somebody who frankly is in
total meltdown now he was found guilty
in like we keep using this word
excoriating what that means is it's like
the most extreme language you can
imagine from a conservative dominated
committee about their own prime minister
from their own party I've never heard
anything quite like it you can't surely
still be defending the guy no look to be
absolutely no no no you're not defending
it I'm not defending him no I'm not
defending oh great right okay okay well
hang on so you agree that no no let me
finish let me finish right okay so a bit
of nuance here that's something
something you might be familiar with
right
um he's got to carry the can for this of
course he has in that he doesn't think
sir well okay but I think it's all a
Witch Hunt so Parliament is corrupt it's
all a Witch Hunt yeah it's been stitched
up it's everybody else's fault but it's
the usual Boris Playbook exactly but
everyone you agree with that most most
of other people in the country say he's
got to carry the can however I think
there is one area where I think he does
have a point which is this this is a
political process not a legal process
this is other politicians judging
another politician if you look at the
severity of the uh of the punishment
that they have dealt out to him it is
way beyond anything that anyone expected
20 days we are actually in um president
attorney we have a prime minister of
this country who has gone to the House
of Commons and brazenly lied we've never
ever had that before no prime minister
in this country's history has ever done
that so this is you well they haven't
well they haven't been caught lying why
they haven't been hang on they haven't
been proven to be Liars 45 minutes fine
there are lots of there are lots of
times you may have thought they were not
telling the full truth but he's the
first Prime Minister where a committee
of his peers inside Parliament have
concluded he lied to Parliament
deliberately and that is you know it's
unconscionable of course no one's saying
that's a good thing it's a terrible
thing right it is a terrible thing but
you've got you've got to look at it with
a little bit of perspective why well
because he was breaking his own rules
rules which meant the queen had to mourn
alone yeah meant that this little boy
Ismail had to be buried alone I know
countless people who had to say goodbye
to their loved ones yeah on face time
videos on their phone because of the
rules that Boris Johnson said now we
find out that every Friday was wine
party time for his own press team and he
wants us to think he didn't know
anything about it happening in his own
building it's complete hogwash he knew
all about all this stuff but the plug it
in he's there but he's in these bashes
but the point hello Jabs carry on don't
worry about the rules for the little
guys but the point is they don't apply
to us it was punished for that because
he lost his job as prime minister yes he
that that was at that time that's that's
the worst so what are you actually
defending him about what I'm saying is
that this that just to me like you
basically agree with me well I agree
with you to a certain extent I'm trying
to work out what part of the extent you
don't agree with he should have carried
the cannon he did but I think this
committee goes way too far so a bunch of
Tories basically have been what partisan
against but you you and I both know your
worst enemies and sat behind you not
opposite you in the House of Commons
it's no it's not good it's not enough to
say just because it's tourists they were
always going to back him right the fact
is a lot of people like all right let me
bring in uh Sir Anthony Selden and I
read your book I told you this on uh on
half term vacation and it was well to
use the phrase of the night excoriating
um so it's no surprise to you I'd
imagine what's happened here but are you
surprised by the way Boris has gone full
Trump I mean literally he is now
attacking every part of our of the
fabric of our institutions of democracy
yeah it's incredibly poor judgment on
his part and also it belittles the
Office of Prime Minister it is the
highest political office in the country
the second highest office to that of
head of state the Monarch and it's
important that people who hold this
office act with um decorum and respect
for the institutions and don't uh Slash
out uh criticizing those people who have
criticized you uh there's no proportion
out there there's no good example so and
look up peers
um as you say uh the book I wrote about
him with Raymond Newell is full of every
single page many
um places uh episodes where he hadn't
read his material where he gave advice
one way and then changed his mind where
he didn't listen to people or listen
listen to the wrong people covered Owen
Artisan leveling up Chris pincher I mean
it just went on and on no one by the end
wanted to work with him now the point I
think AIDS the point it was a disaster
it was a fiasco it was a fiasco and your
book makes it crystal clear in gruesome
detail why it was such a an embarrassing
farce I think the point is it's not
about cake at birthday parties amongst
colleagues that's not what this is about
it's far more serious than that it's
about a prime minister who set very
Draconian rules for the people of this
country which most people followed
assiduously many people were fined for
breaking so they took this seriously and
now it's turned out from this report
that all the time the Downing street
view of this from masks to social
distancing to any of it was basically to
to laugh at the country to mock them to
say ah that the rules of the other
people none of this applies to us in
here we're like Mr louisis but they
learned they were at the center of
British democracy number 10 Downing
Street setting rules they were
flagrantly breaking and the guy at the
top knew all about it and then went to
Parliament and lied to his MPS and I'm
not sure he gets more serious than that
so some perspective there he was the
most chaotic prime minister since the
modern office was created under Lloyd
George in 1916 no prime minister I mean
there might have been unsuccessful uh
ones Theresa May wasn't hugely
successful but she acted with great
integrity who worked hard she read her
paper she tried to write Solutions
she absolutely was absolutely she tried
her hardest many of them have they're
conscious of the incredible honor of
being at the head of their government uh
the culmination of their life the job
that so many everyone in politics wants
to have and it's it's essential that you
behave with decorum but also no post
prime minister has behaved like this uh
Anthony Eden was accused of lying to the
house uh during the Suez Crisis uh Tony
Blair over as we heard the 45 minutes
but both of them were meticulous people
who slaved away at their job and and uh
did their best even if it was wrong for
their country this is a very different
kind of person and neither of them would
seek to denigrate the Judiciary
Parliament uh their own party it's
um it's serious it is it is like okay
everyone's confidence yeah we're gonna
have a debate off the break with a
different panel about can Boris make a
comeback I would say I don't think he
deserves to make a comeback but before
we go to that just quickly Sir Anthony
do you think he will
I think he'll try because I don't think
he does think that he's done anything
wrong any more than he did at the
telegraph or The Spectator or as uh
mayor of London or as an MP uh or when
he was at school or when he was at
University he he never accepts that he
makes any mistakes so I think he'll try
uh and who knows I mean he is a a
politician unlike any politician since
Tony Blair in terms of his reach uh and
his Charisma uh he'll try but I can't
see it happening anytime yet because
even conservatives especially brexiteers
no longer trust him and no longer think
he's a conservative okay and very
quickly uh Alex do you think he'll be
back in any meaningful political way I
think he wants to be but obviously it's
incredibly should he be I think most
people will think not what do you think
I think probably the party needs to work
out how to how to deliver it out man
come on no the what do you actually
think what do you believe you're free
you can save your life well I believe
you've got your Obe whatever it is the
party's got to learn to probably live
without him okay so he's done says the
guy he's literally just gotten honor
from him the meeting Westminster is that
most of them are are done and actually
it would take quite a lot for him to be
able to get on the candidates list I
think in the film I think he's got two
hopes no hope and Bob Hope but thank you
to my panel uh much appreciated to all
of you on sensitive next so does Teflon
Johnson have any political future we'll
debate that next even though my view is
quite clear
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
conservative MP across the pond uh
Louise Mensch well there's a new yougov
poll out that says 69 of the British
public think the Boris Johnson
deliberately lied to Parliament 14 think
he didn't and interestingly uh 51 of
conservatives think you lied to
Parliament so even his own lot thank you
Eli department has also been an advisor
a former advisor called James Johnson to
Theresa May is now a pollster has told
Sky News that only 17 of people have a
positive view of Boris Johnson these
days 62 negative and he said for context
that means Boris Johnson is now more
unpopular with the British public than
Phillip Schofield or Xi Jinping of China
which is quite something quite something
uh all right
uh Isabel that's I mean that's sorry but
that polling is absolutely ridiculous
public you're wrong again of course
they're being negative about him this
week but give it a few weeks and it'll
blow over a bit why should it blow over
seriously why should it blow over
honestly to recycle an old argument
because there are so many bigger things
to worry about than a prime minister
lines he's not the Prime Minister
anymore but he was gone it was gone and
he's the first Prime Minister ever to be
censored in this way I know I know but
but what is it make you feel like what's
the point of continuing to froth at the
mouth about this well we're not at the
moment we're involved in ongoing Story
the reports literally just come out
you're one of these people that says
it's far too it's too late to talk about
this and the next thing is too soon
there's never a good time is there no I
think to deliberate this scandalous
behavior of the conservative prime
minister it's not politics but I just
think we are now wasting energy on this
the guy is finished in the conservative
party I cannot see what if he is if he
is then this is energy Well Spent My
worry Richard says I have to be honest
is that he will try and make a comeback
and rather like Donald Trump in America
there's a constituent of people out
there where the worse he bathes the more
lies he tells the less he honors
democracy the more he attacks the
fundamental Bedrock of our democratic
system they stay with him
and but that's the joy of democracy
peers you know everybody is entitled to
vote for who they want to but I think
there's a serious Point here which is
that this Committee in saying that you
can't even challenge their judgments you
can't even question it that actually is
against free
what would you challenge oh well the
point is he's allowed to challenge it if
he wants what would you charge you chat
what would I challenge
um I think the by the way he's allowed
to challenge you he's given it two weeks
in advance but he's had to go back and
say that you know but the fact the fact
that they increase the sentence because
he criticized it I think as an attack on
Free Speech
that's the only Point all right they're
all doubting what he's done no one's
doubting I don't agree with you and I
think Paul is going to say what I'm
about I think I think we think myself to
be clear about this he wasn't he didn't
received the further reprimand because
he didn't agree with the report he
received the further reprimon because he
was told that it was a confidential
document he was supposed to respect the
confidentiality and he failed to do that
this is another example of Boris Johnson
accountability
allowed Democratic accountability when
he himself is attacking the very idea of
democracy out of Interest look he's not
he's not attacking democracy oh yes he
is we have a democratic process yes
Parliament is the absolute problem and
no one's doubted and this guy is saying
the whole thing's corrupt it's all a
Witch Hunt there are a bunch of liars
which I don't think I've ever seen I've
never seen a former prime minister
try to damage the institution of
democracy in this way ever well it is
trumpet it's the way Trump attacks it is
Champion but actually feel comfortable
about that I'm not feeling comfortable
about what if no one's doubting what he
did he misled Parliament there's no
question he lied to Parliament and the
likelihood is that he deliberately lied
to Parliament he obviously denies that
but I think you cannot say he can't
question the report and to increase his
sentence because he had the temerity to
question it that I think is vindictive
because he had
exactly it was a confidential document
but one that he knew that he was
supposed to respect the confidentiality
and he decided to completely disregard
here's what he did
give him the report two weeks before
he studied it he realized he was going
down right he realized he would have to
probably lose his seat he realized the
game was up so he did so he did what
Trump did yeah when Trump blew it up he
just blew up blew up the whole thing and
has carried on blowing it up right and
my answer to that is we should just
that's enough Boris we don't have to go
down the American route he just comes
back and does it all over again we don't
so you only you only believe in free
speech when it suits no no that's the
point no no no no no no no no once again
Paul is completely right
maybe we should go to your own partner
and get her to explain why you're wrong
Isabel because you're
because the point is that he shouldn't
have criticized it before it came out
because that is the agreement and it was
like it's basically like he broke the
embarked it's not a free speech nation
that he shouldn't have done it's not a
free speeches it's about him
deliberately torching the conventional
process of how these things are reported
to the public and he knew what he was
doing they they said they they increased
the sentence right because he challenged
their report did he challenge the report
because he broke every rule around the
release of the report and then he
torched at the very idea of democracy
and he's a prime minister for God's sake
former prime minister until recently a
prime minister the most powerful
politician in this country and he's
talking democracy and he's paid the
price yeah so he should I'm actually
getting fed up with people trying to
defend Boris Johnson he's not this
cuddly lovable guy that all his
supporters
I assume this report is a guy who
systematically lied lied lied it's not
the first time on that Rodeo he lied he
lied when he was fired from a newspaper
the times for making up stories he lied
when by when he lied to Michael Howard
about an affair at the Specter and so on
you know Boris has always lied we all
know that and it was kind of funny for a
while until he started doing it over
covid but people were dying and can I
make a prediction here because I don't
think he's going to make a comeback
actually I don't think this is at all
about him making a comeback I think what
this is about is him making himself this
figure of of intrigue of okay
Louise Louise has been waiting very
patiently I'm so thoroughly enjoying the
debate but I completely forgotten you're
over there and Louise okay well you're
gonna try and defend the indefensible
are you yes I am but I don't think it is
indefensible I'm a bit of a Sticky
Wicket if you're fed up with hearing
people's defend Boris Johnson because
that's what I'm just about to do
somebody has to push back on you as
great as you are saying throughout this
show saying throughout this show that
Boris Johnson has been attacking
democracy and attacking Parliament this
committee this little quango is not the
same thing as parliament
of the committee of the forest
parliamentarians led by four out of the
seven being conservatives they're your
people
against MPS and guess what a bunch of
Tories found out that their Tori was a
liar that's it so a labor things
I didn't do it it's the Tory party
people who did it
peers the committee hasn't just
threatened Boris Johnson and by the way
how do you know that it was only 40 days
originally you know that because this
committee themselves have been leaking
they didn't just threaten Boris Johnson
they came out um a couple of days ago
and they started throwing their weight
around and threatening not only Boris
but any of his supporters in Parliament
who also criticized them they think that
they are above the law and it's a small
group of people that have done this now
I've read this report and I don't agree
with you I don't think it is a
meticulous piece of work what and I
don't think your viewers universally
held I see the times I see the telegraph
the headlines today lots of people
saying that they've gone way too far
that it's spiteful and that it is over
the top now is Boris finish and you
don't think boris's response has been
spiteful and over the top
no I think he's entitled to defend
himself
he said the whole thing's a stitched up
they're all a bunch of liars that's
called Free Speech maybe believe in it
no no I do believe in it I do when it
doesn't see you no no yes you're getting
me completely wrong I believe in free
speech I don't believe in him torching
the process of these people yes
so Louise do you think Boris can
actually make a comeback and if so why
yes he can and the answer to why is
quite simply as whoever it was said
events to avoid events he's not going to
be able to make a comeback before the
election that is obvious and I think
he's leaked his plans if you like to the
times tonight when he has said that he's
waiting for Rishi stunnak to lose the
election disastrously and even then he's
not going to try and come back
immediately he's going to wait for
somebody to follow Rishi and not to land
a blow on kirst Armor and then when the
conservatives are tired of losing that's
when they might go back to the guy who
delivered an 80 seat majority so well he
did deliver it and then I think he'll be
the only one and then he squandered it
and he squandered it because he kept
lying and he kept he kept breaking the
rules that he set for everybody else and
unfortunately when you do that as prime
minister people don't like it it turns
out who knew he said well can you make a
comeback and I just cannot see it in the
conservative party no I mean maybe he
can do it outside the conservative what
about the Reform Party well I think
that's a bit awkward
I mean
Tuesday night I'm happy to repeat the
point how would you feel if you wanted
to come and run the Reform Party look
the point is we've got money you look
down a bit nervous we've got massive
differences about Net Zero about
immigration where we have the similarity
is doing brexit properly and would you
stand around and stand aside with the
people around him he failed to do so
would you stand aside for him it's it's
not an issue because that's a winner I
mean it's it's why wouldn't you it's a
it's a hypothetical question
that we've got massive difference but
you believe in free speech yes so so
I've asked you a question
in the spirit of free speech we've got
massive differences that is the key you
wouldn't want him running the party but
I don't think anyone I don't want any
running the party
the clear principles that I agree with
to be clear you don't want him to run
the party to be clear no one should run
our party that doesn't agree with our
people sounding like a politician oh you
are a politician come on should he run
the party yes or no he's not going to
run the party that's absolutely no sense
you're asking an absurd hypothetical
question we fundamentally disagree on
some major issues to the question if
it's so obsessed
I think you need to rephrase the
question peers and you might get
somewhere the fact well how would you
phrase it you obviously know the right
questions
I'm just okay let me put it this way do
you think you could work with him
good question good quote on brexit yes
on brexit on brexit we should do it look
we've left we should do it properly or
not do it so you can work with Boris
Johnson Reform Party on brexit you could
work with him in a in some form the
doors open you're inviting a minute what
I'm saying is serial liar you're happy
to have what I'm working in your party
that's not what I'm saying that's not
what he's a Serial line
that's not what I'm saying please
all of us practices should work together
okay as I'm confused whether that door's
open I'll shut up and the spirit of free
speech we're going to move on thank you
uh to my thank you Louise over in
America on since the next cycling
Champion Hannah arenzman has quit the
sport of losing to controversial trans
cyclist Austin Phillips who beat all her
biological female Rivals are five
minutes in a recent race well the person
who's now quit the sport because of this
fast is joining me next and I'll be
joined by the former British Olympic
swimmer and one Women's Rights Campaign
at Sharon Davis has a new book out about
this and has been one of the bravest
voices in all this nonsense that's after
the break
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Pittsburgh on Central
women's cycling Champion Hannah arenzman
quickly support us losing to
controversial transgender competitor
Austin killins in December abandoning
her dream of competing in the Paris
Olympics in 2024 footage from that race
shows killip's shoving Arrangement
causing outrage that the six foot tall
very muscular born male used
intimidation to get ahead but last
weekend Austin Killers won another race
in North Carolina by five entire minutes
in a moment I'll get the view of former
Olympic swimming champion and author of
a new book unfair play Sharon Davis but
first i'm joined by Hannah arenzman from
United States Hannah when you see just
that bit of footage there the the brutal
way was sort of shoved away but in a way
that's kind of what's happening in
women's sport generally right a bunch of
trans athletes have come along and are
shoving biological females out the way
absolutely it's it's very disheartening
to see in all sorts of levels and it's
not just the elite it's also every level
starting from open women all the way up
um so yeah it's very sad honey you've
actually quit the sport which is
incredibly depressing that you've been
forced to do this why did you come to
that decision
there are multiple reasons but it was
definitely very disheartening to leave
my last race and be flanked on either
side
of the national cycle cross championship
by two men on the elite women's race
and these are men who are now trans
women but they're biological men and
this is an issue now not just affecting
cycling but we're seeing it in all sorts
of other sports do you feel Hannah
obviously it's such a Hot Topic it's so
incendiary very few people want to put
their heads over the parapet do you feel
a lot of female athletes and sports
women share your view but are just too
intimidated to say it
yes Lots even in the cycling Community
which
on the front looks very Pro guys racing
in our field but the women quietly try
to find ways to let their voice be heard
by either contacting the governing
bodies or just trying to make other
people wear around that this is not okay
it's not fair and biologically you can
never make it fair it's completely
unfair well thank you very much indeed
uh and I'm just so sorry about what's
happened to you Sharon let me come to
you because you've written this great
book The Battle of a women's sport
that's what it is it's a battle for the
heart and soul and integrity of a sport
that you Grace so brilliantly I mean I
go back to when you got cheated out of a
gold medal at the Olympics because of
the doping that was going on with with
the East uh Germans wasn't it at the
time and you should have won Gold and
you didn't because you had a bunch of
doping cheats uh at the time is it that
different now well it's exactly the same
except it's a different process you know
what what happened way back then in the
70s and the 80s that they were taking 11
and 12 year old girls and giving them
testosterone and putting them through a
male puberty and they totally and
utterly dominated for 20 years the iot
did nothing so to the level of the
European championships they won 90 of
the women's medals you know just
stratopheric you know improvements and
perhaps nothing in the men's and so that
was because they were given this
additional testosterone which is still
less than what you would have if you
were biologically male so we're now
asking our female athletes to race
people that have gone through the whole
of puberty there's 17 peer-reviewed
studies out there not single one says
that we can remove you know that male
biology and that and that Advantage so
we're knowingly making our girls race
against an advantage before they even
start which the men are never asked to
do and that's what's so frustrating is
that the men would not put up with this
and also there's no issue with trans men
right competing against biological don't
because they can't yeah they don't
that's why we separate the Sexes at the
Olympics I mean that's why we do it
that's exactly it you know we have
categories and all sorts of things we
have obviously the biggest one is male
female then we have all the weight
categories we have all the paralympic
but the worst thing is the worst thing
shown is that very mediocre competitors
when they identify as their biological
sex
then become World beaters when they put
their hands up and say I'm now a woman
yeah and compete against biological
females that's my problem with it it's
just then often they're not very good
competing as men but as women they're
World beaters yeah that's the thing you
know something like swimming it's 11 the
difference between male and female
performance so you get someone like Leah
Thomas who was
465th in America over 2000s in the world
would never have made nc2a finals which
is the Collegiate files in America
competing as a man transitions for one
year and beats three American Olympic
silver medalists it's ridiculous it is
it's actually maddening and what's even
more maddening people like you and I've
what I've followed I'm so glad you come
on the show because I've been trying to
get you phrases just to say thank you
for what you've been doing thank you
because I've watched the abuse that
comes your way right the the viciousness
the you're a bigger you're a transphobe
almost it's all complete nonsense you're
just standing up the women's rights to
equality it's really what you do yeah
and I'm not anti-trans at all you know I
believe we should have the debate find a
place for everybody to do sport I love
sports it's been my life I want everyone
to be able to do sport however it must
be fair and safe it must be safe first
then it must be fair then we will find
ways to be inclusive and I've always
advocated for the female Caspian and
open category you know you mentioned
trans men and trans men that are on
testosterone have nowhere to race and no
one ever talks about them because they
don't matter because they're females
right but actually if we have this open
category they would have so much a race
as well yeah you either compete against
your biological sex so if you're a trans
woman you compete against biological
males as many of them have done before
or you have a different category of his
own yeah what you can't do you cannot
continue to allow biological males to
demolish biological females otherwise
the Integrity of women's sport is
disintegrated I know and it's not just
that it's
small piece of a cake anyway peers you
know in this country for example there's
a thousand women earning their living
from sport there's eleven thousand men
in America one percent of the
sponsorship dollar goes to women one
percent yeah four percent goes in a
Prime Time Sports air time our piece of
the cake is Tiny and now we're being
asked to budge over for biological males
it's it's just infuriating and the book
shows throughout the whole history this
has been the case no no it's brilliantly
researched but I I do come back to this
thing that basically it's the new form
of doping it's the new form of cheating
everybody knows it gives them an unfair
advantage and it's not transphobic I
support trans people's rights to
fairness and equality but why should
that come at the expense of fairness
safety and equality for women it
shouldn't really no it really shouldn't
you know we thought very hard to try and
get equality we're nowhere near it but
we are getting there and now this is a
massive step backwards and it and it is
a parallel with those East German years
it is that's probably why I speak out
because I saw so many of my friends you
know lose out I have friends that came
forth behind threes Germans no one's
ever remembered and I read that you met
the East German who beat you and she
recently and she offered to give you her
medal yeah she did so she knew yeah they
did know you know they know that they
were part of a system right they were
part of the system I don't have any
issues with them as individuals at all
in fact you know I believe they were
very much victims of the system yeah I
agree the ISC are extremely responsible
for all of this they are not the ISE are
not to be held up as exactly I totally
agree keep keep doing this thank you
very much because you're doing an
incredibly important job and it's a
brave and lonely place to be it's
getting better it's getting busier it is
uh and eventually justice will prevail
and Common Sense will prevail it's
called the battle for women's sport
unfair play by Sharon Davis a fantastic
book if you want to know why it's so
unfair and why it's so important to have
this debate and to avoid all the
nonsensical abuse that goes with it read
this book Sharon good to see you thank
you
and says the next rainbow flags have
been replacing Union Jacks and the stars
and stripes across the UK and us always
wound a few people up including Tommy
lahren well debate next why
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
coming up on The Talk The Party gate
report finds Boris Johnson misled
Parliament but he slams it as a
political assassination
the Army's considering scrapping titles
like Rifleman and Guardsmen to be gender
neutral and pop star Craig David says
he's gone celibate that's all at nine
o'clock
[Music]
well welcome back you may have noticed
it's pride month it's pretty hard to
ignore it the rainbow flag has been
posted over London's region Street the
place of Union Jack and Drake from the
White House balcony in place of a Star
Spangled Banner which has sparked quite
a backlash in the states have we gone
rainbow crazy or is pride month more
important than patriotism or debate this
I'm joined by Fox news commentator Tommy
layering and I'm a studio the comedian
James but all right Tommy off you go
you're enraged by this why
well listen I wouldn't say I am enraged
by it but I am irritated and a lot of
American conservatives agree with me now
listen pride month is not a new thing
they've been celebrating pride month for
many many years and most American
conservatives had no issue with it until
it became
forceful until it became the need for
acknowledgment the need for four
celebration the need for Force
validation that's when you lost people
and then we took LGB and then we added
lgbtqia plus plus and then we included
men who dress up like women and mock
women like influencer Dylan Mulvaney and
that a lot of American conservatives
just said listen we've had enough it's
okay if you're proud of your sexuality
but why do I have to be proud of your
sexuality that's where you lost a lot of
folks and we're starting to fight but
first they'll say Okay trans woman Dylan
is a woman so you got that wrong and
secondly well Dylan was Dylan was a gay
man until last year I Dylan was a gay
man until last year transitioned they're
a woman I think that we lost people
right at the beginning when gay people
were dying in the streets because no one
was looking out for us so actually what
we're doing right now is just I wouldn't
even use the word celebrating I think
pride is a protest has it been is it a
bit too much in other words do you want
to what does that mean what is too much
in other words I think with every
campaign bringing people with you is
really important right the moment it
looks like it's just over the top like
it's everywhere you go it's Pride Prime
do we need to be that well are you
blaming gay people for that I mean oh I
thought the company honestly I don't
care what sexuality anybody is I don't
think most people do anymore right so
what is the problem then why are you so
triggered here's a buy a flower
attention I'm not triggered by a rainbow
flag I'm triggered by the fact that
everywhere I go for a gallon a month
everything has to be a rainbow flag
until I'm triggered that everywhere I go
for the entire year everything has to be
straight where is it why is straight
where's my Straight flag why am I
constantly straight flowers straight
people holding hands in a straight flag
why is Mickey Mouse tell me one straight
flag how are you right about anywhere in
the world why are straight people
identity where's the straight flag
everywhere where's my Straight flag it's
everywhere it's never been a straight
flag you're a straight flag
let me bring Tommy back because this
made me laugh Demi Lovato has revealed
she got tired of using they them
pronouns due to constantly having to
educate people about it she said it was
exhausting what I know the feeling uh
Demi she's exhausting isn't she Tommy
it's all exhausting listen nobody cares
what you choose to be it's just this
everybody has to keep up with what you
feel like today or tomorrow everybody
has to change the way that they address
you and if somebody heaven forbid makes
a mistake then all of a sudden they're a
transphobe and they're akin to a
domestic terrorist is absolutely
ludicrous it's absolutely not true
that's right and by the way how many
letters are there now no I let you talk
exactly it lets you talk if Fitness told
me yeah I finished you're right finish
your point
yeah and there's another part of this
whole pride thing listen if it was just
rainbows and love is love there's no
problem with that if you look at a nine
or ten of these Pride events it's grown
men and grown women wearing bondage gear
smacking each other often children are
involved to watch this special I mean my
goodness if you want equality
they Sam is that they pronoun sorry
please Sam used to be a he too right and
we can't keep up with any of them Demi
Lovato used to be there
72 countries in the world where it's
illegal to be gay that's why ask me one
and I'm with you on gay rights to
equality absolutely 100 always happy
answer one question how many letters are
there now on the official Point let's go
how many are there it's a flag that
represents how many that don't even know
how many are there I don't need exactly
right I don't need to know because it's
not about there are so many letters now
we can't keep up with it's not about
that it's about inclusion
and now we found out according to uh to
the John Hopkins Medical University in
Baltimore that apparently lesbians are
now no men no man who have relationships
with no men no men in non-man having a
ratio of the non-main I don't I
personally don't even know what you're
talking about well nobody knows what
they're talking about my flag is there
to represent lgbtq plus people and
minorities and like all sorts of
movement like black lives matter the
reason it's so loud and to quote you
exhausting okay because we need to all
right but I do want to come back next
time I speak to you to the straight flag
that you say exists which I've never
seen right because I want my own
straight Flags Tommy great to see you uh
great to see you may I wish you happy
pride month you may go on
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]